guys I'm here with Anna Akana you have
one of the most fun names to say out
loud
thank you do you get that a lot all the
time well I'm glad to be in the majority
yeah today we are gonna do the balloon
challenge which is as easy as you can
assume we are going to compete to pop
the most amount of balloon I think I'm
gonna win yeah I invited Anna over to
create some really groundbreaking
content today you guys round one we get
to use our bare hands and we have 15
seconds one at a time to pop as many
balloons as we can round two we wear
oven mitts and we'll have 30 seconds
round three we were oven mitts and a
blindfold and we have 45 seconds okay
does all that make sense to you yes and
then the winner is the one that pops the
most of them what do I win well I think
just a sense of pride okay and and and
admiration from all of us
I'll take it being a gracious host I
will let you go first
okay so Jack Perry will you keep the
time on the clock yes
okay you tell us when I'll hand you the
balloons because it'll be a team effort
perfect ready set go today one cat we
could count the throwers count these
guys a little knows of us so no okay six
seven eight okay I have to beat eight
okay Cara is this weirdly so stressful
okay I'm ready set go
oh really fun challenge
did anyone count thank you goodbye
five okay so Anna takes the first round
oven mitts on and thirty seconds on the
clock this is where I think it gets okay
ready
oh yeah you got you
I mean I do think you could get more
stressed definitely got more stressful
ready set go
No
I like sweating same same time oh then
that means that we are tied which takes
us into the final round
Wow can you see anything negative can
you breathe
I can okay there you go
okay you look great thank you ready let
go thank you oh man she might pop all
the balloons
oh god you're doing it you're gonna you
oh oh oh there you go I don't know if
the blindfold is doing
okay you go there you know wow you
popped all the blue which is great so I
have to go this if this isn't teach you
guys all the skill sets that we have
that maybe you didn't think we had I
don't know how it will I'm out of breath
on your behalf
also I felt like this was a weird
sorority initiation yeah like put these
weird oven mitts on and pop these
balloons you guys if you're really
really that upset that I didn't get to
compete in round three um I think you
should just channel that anger into
something creative in your life maybe
I'll pop some balloons for yourself
because clearly aniseh is a champion at
this and you know what else does
champion of talking which is what we're
gonna do we're filming a podcast the not
too deep podcast make sure you go listen
to it over on soundcloud or itunes to
hear anna's episode and where's the best
way for them to see you on the internet
doing things that are not this youtube
also okay a channel is just my name Oh
perfect cuz you have your podcast up
there as well yeah very cool and you're
a clothing line oh yes I do
ghost and star scoffs so many things so
go check it out thank you for
participating in the dumbest thing we've
ever done
thank you yeah I won the dumbest thing I
don't know do you have any particular
pet peeves
yeah I'm really like OCD so if like
things aren't in their place I get very
upset with my boyfriend so have you guys
set like ground rules on that kind of
thing
I have said a lot of ground yeah does he
know about that so he's starting to
realize them these let's figure it out
after all the yelling happen yeah